gut dann begrüßte sie zur heutigen
sitzung in der wir uns mit der
geschichte der philosophie der tiere
beschäftigen werden nämlich mit rené
descartes und mit tanya und sie haben
sicherlich gesehen dass die beiden ganz
verschiedene auffassungen vertreten was
den geist der tiere anbelangt zu beginn
würde ich gerne noch mal eine kurze
wiederholung machen weil ja eine sitzung
ausgefallen ist dazwischen können sie
mir noch mal kurz sagen was wir unter
dem geist der tiere verstehen wollen
also was wir nicht unter geist verstehen
wollen und was darunter fällt wenn sie
merken ja sicherlich es hängt wesentlich
davon ab was man unter geist versteht ob
man tieren dann am ende ein geist zu
sprechen kann oder nicht vergessen auf
dem vortrag eines philosophen und der
hat die these vertreten dass die tiere
keinen geist hätten weil sie nicht
zuhören fähigkeiten in der lage sind
doch keine höheren fähigkeiten verfügen
wie zb kultur oder sonstige dinge die
wir als geistige produkte bezeichnen wer
von ihnen kann noch mal kurz sagen wie
man jetzt ganz so bestimmen könnte das
vielleicht tiere auch geist besitzen
wissen sie noch welches geistes wir hier
an die tafel geschrieben hatten
überlegen sie mal was ist ein geistiger
akt oder geistiges merkmal
[Musik]
genau machen können sie auch mal kurz
sagen was qualia sind ja ich denke dass
gegen die richtige richtung qual ist
lateinisch wie sie beschaffen wir sind
also wie zuständig könnte man sagen also
wie es sich anfühlt schmerz zu haben
also individuelle individuelles
phänomenales bewusst sein könnte man
auch sagen ja gefühle
zustände wie gefühle wie zustände ist
vielleicht der beste begriff die beste
übersetzung ja genau und also sie haben
gesagt meint das englische wort meint
wir hatten gesehen dass deutsche wort
geist hat viel mehr bedeutung als meint
der wesentliche unterschied ist der dass
meint immer auf das objekt bezogen ist
oder genau genommen auf die psyche auf
psychische aktivitäten das mentale
könnte man auch sagen dass mental und es
ist ja unbestritten dass tiere über
mentale eigenschaften verfügen
das ist unbestritten insofern muss man
immer schon die frage haben tiere geist
wenn wir uns an geist wir verwenden
heutiger erkenntnis der
naturwissenschaften eigentlich diese
frage immer bejahen wenn wir einen sehr
spezifischen geist begriff wir jetzt den
das mentalen verwenden es ist allerdings
ein recht weiter mit griff er ist nicht
so spezifisch recht weit alles mentale
und natürlich sagen uns die modernen
naturwissenschaften verfügen tiere über
mentale eigenschaften ganz klar
sie empfinden schmerzen wir werden jetzt
heute descartes lesen der solche dinge
er bestreitet aber das ist sicherlich
überholt nicht nichtsdestotrotz finden
sich bei descartes wichtige argumente
hinsichtlich dieser frage ob tiere an
geist besitzen
das problem ist schon wenn man sagt
geist der tiere wenn man der geist sagt
liegt irgendwie die vermutung nahe der
geist ist irgendwie so
ein komplexes phänomen das es schon
subjekt das in den tieren wird wie auch
immer wenn man jetzt sagt das mentale
der tiere mentale eigenschaften bei
denen ist es relativ unstrittig dass
tiere über sowas verfügen man muss jetzt
genauer klären noch welche mit über
welche mentalen eigenschaften tiere
verfügen
und da wird es dann plötzlich
interessant weil dann gibts sowas wie
sprache
das hat mir das letzte mal mit diesem
code im affen diskutiert in der
zusammenfassung die offensichtlich
hoffentlich jeder von ihnen bekommen hat
oder gibt es jemand unter ihnen der die
e mail nicht bekommen hat dann schreiben
sie mir einfach eine e-mail weil ich
bekomme immer man ab und zu eine e mail
wieder zurück an hals die konnte nicht
gesendet werden
also wir keine e-mails wöchentlich
bekommt schreibt mir einfach noch mal
eine e mail dass ich ihn mit der
richtigen e mail aufnehmen wir hatten
diesen coco den affen der skurriler
weibchen coco was doch sehr sehr
eloquent zu sein schienen da hat sich
eine diskussion entspann hat jetzt coco
tatsächlich eine sprache auch mit der
sprache verhält es sich ähnlich wie mit
dem geist es gibt einen weiten begriff
von sprache und in engen begriffen
sprache der weiter begriff von sprache
heißt es ist eine kommunikations frau
coco kann kommunizieren kann sich
verständigen
es werde weiter begriffen es gibt aber
in engeren begriffen sprache und nach
sprache es über sowas verfügen muss wie
semantische bedeutung lehre also man
muss jedes zeichen muss eine bedeutung
haben und je nachdem wie man dann diese
zeichen anordnet syntax die
zusammenstellung ergibt sich eine andere
bedeutung
also kann der affe müsste man dann
prüfen verwendet er nur bestimmte
zeichen in einer beliebigen reihenfolge
oder ist ja in der lage diese zeichen so
zu kombinieren um neue bedeutung zu
generieren
die karte wird dieses argument gegen den
geist der tiere ein anbringen also sagt
gerade wegen dieser fehlenden
flexibilität der zusammensetzung von
zeichen
gerade deswegen dürfen die tieren keine
sprache zu sprechen also das nicht
annehmen
also sehen immer das hängt ganz davon ab
wie weit wir den begriff fassen wenn man
sprache sehr weit fasst dann denke ich
ist es unstrittig dass tiere darüber
verfügen das sie kommunizieren dass ich
das mitteilt bestimmte dinge mitteilen
können werden wir ihn eher eng fassen
dann wird es besonders spannend
das heißt wir haben die begriffe die wir
hier jetzt zugrunde liegen eher in einem
engeren sinn zu verwirken ganz
spezifisch sprache selbstbewusstsein
solche phänomene interessieren uns dass
tiere über schmerz fast ihren schmerz
verspüren können und darauf reagieren
können ist unstrittig dass würde so gut
wie niemand bestreiten dass tiere
phänomenales bewusstsein haben hier
zum beispiel zum beispiel die haben aber
guter hinweis wir sind die meisten von
uns sind natürlich keine tierforscher
keine verhaltensforschers und wir sind
wieder so viele studenten das heißt es
ist ein meteorologisches problem wie
prüfen wir nach ob jetzt diese
eigenschaften vorliegt oder nicht dann
müssen wir notwendigerweise auf die
erkenntnisse der altersforschung
eingehen nur das hatte ich auch schon in
einer sitzung gesagt glaube ich auch
eine zusammenfassung geschrieben
ergebnisse empirische ergebnisse
sprechen für sich selbst sie müssen
immer interpretiert werden
und die frage ist dann immer wenn wir
die daten vorliegen haben was machen wir
da raus und sie haben jetzt einen
vorschlag macht ja ich kenne mich jetzt
nicht so sehr aus mit kränen ich glaube
aber auch dass es sehr intelligent sind
weil sie zum beispiel nüsse auf die
straße fallen lassen und dann warten bis
ein auto drüber fährt und dass die nuss
knackt das ist schon so was wie
instrumentelle intelligenz mit diesen
krächzen müsste man jetzt die neueste
forschung sich anschauen ist auf jeden
fall ein möglicher punkt dass
intelligenz nicht unbedingt mit dem
komplexen sprachsystem einhergehen muss
das müssen wir noch prüfen in der
heutigen sitzung geht es jetzt aber
erstmal um historische position nämlich
um die karts und montania und wir wollen
uns jetzt zunächst die frage stellen
warum nach descartes tiere keinen geist
besitzen welche argumente anführen
und er hat interessante argumente die
immer auch wieder in der neueren debatte
eingeführt werden genauso kann man sich
fragen warum inwiefern nach mondaine die
tiere jetzt ein geist haben die szene
sind antagonisten hinsichtlich dieser
auffassung dann zum schluss wir wollen
ja nicht nur schauen was wann wo gesagt
wurde sondern wir wollen immer auch
prüfen ob das was gesagt wurde
überzeugend
und diese frage wollen wir uns am ende
der heutigen sitzung stellen welche
auffassung überzeugender ist bevor wir
jetzt auf die texte eingehen habe ich
ihnen hier noch so ein schönes bildchen
und wer kann von einmal beschreiben was
darauf zu sehen ist was für eine
auffassung des tierischen hier diesem
dieser skizze zu grunde liegt wer könnte
so ein bildchen zeichnen beschreiben sie
es mal ein bisschen genau richtig
beschreiben sie ein bisschen was ist
maschinell an diesem tier
hmm
genau hier oben ist so ein trichter noch
neues und richter
es wird eingetrichtert dass die
speiseröhre hier unten also hier
befinden sich zahnräder die ineinander
greifen was haben sie als eine turbine
ja batterien könnte es sein das ist aus
dem 18 jahrhundert es gab damals glaube
ich schon zuvor form von batterien aber
noch nicht das glaube man hat damit
schon experimentiert
hier ist irgendwie so ein gummischlauch
und hier irgendwas wieder raus und auch
hier sehen sie sind zahnräder die füße
sind mit zahnrädern verbunden ja also
alles mechanisch mechanistisch
auffassung eines tieres ist hier als
maschine und das natürlich eine ente so
das ist glaube ich sehr treffend gibt
dass diese wie sie richtig sagten diese
position von descartes wieder und jetzt
wolle man aber genau in diesen text
hineinschauen und hat das ihren ganz
kurzen abschnitt sie sehen dass sie nur
vier seiten drei bis vier seiten hier
von der mit unterschied dass der
menschlichen seele von der der tiere
wollen wir jetzt mal uns gemeinsam
anschauen und ich lese einfach mal
wieder vor und wir diskutieren jedes
zitat versichert sagt wenn es maschine
mit den organen und der gestalt eines
affen oder eines anderen vernunft losen
tieres gebe
so hätten wir gar kein mittel das uns
nur den geringsten unterschied erkennen
ließe zwischen dem mechanismus dieser
maschinen und dem lebensprinzip dieser
tiere gebe es dagegen maschinen die
unseren leibern endeten und unsere
handlungen insoweit nachahmten
wie dies für maschinen wahrscheinlich
möglich ist zu hätten wir immer zwei
ganz sichere mittel zu der erkenntnis
dass sie deswegen keineswegs waren
menschen sind also was ist jetzt in
diesem zitat wir müssen jetzt noch
genauer auf diese sicheren kennzeichen
und die sicheren mittel eingehen aber
jetzt mal nur von diesem zitat ausgehend
was ist die these beide karten
hmm
richtig also sagen richtig unterscheiden
es geht um die erkenntnistheorie wir
haben erkenntnisse theoretisch keine
prinzipiell eigentlich keine möglichkeit
zwischen maschinen tieren und sonstigen
tieren lebendigen tieren nicht maschinen
tieren zu unterscheiden das ist also
eine epidemiologische angelegenheit wir
können es nicht erkennen
es könnte prinzipiell dasselbe star
sortiert zombies oder wie auch immer
thema china wir können es nicht erkennen
und jetzt kann man sich ja fragen warum
kann man es nicht erkennen und noch eine
frage ist die warum können wir es beim
menschen aber erkennen also warum geht
das beim menschen nicht
das ist jetzt die frage warum können wir
menschen ansehen ob sie maschinen sind
also ansehen oder erkennt ob sie
maschinen sind oder eben nicht warum
sollte das nach dem kauf möglich sein
gegensatz zu tieren das ist jetzt die
frage wer jetzt sagt er hier es gibt
zwei sichere mittel zu der erkenntnis
dass sie nie waren menschen sein können
wenn sie maschinen sind oder anders
gesagt tiere wenn sie maschinen sind
können wahre tiere seien
das scheint so indirekt raus zu folgen
keine waren menschen und im
umkehrschluss könnte man sagen es würde
hinsicht unseres verhältnisses zu tieren
nichts daran ändern
ein tier ist einfach sowas konzipieren
vielleicht jetzt nicht mit solchen
zahlen rädern drin aber im prinzip ist
es eine maschine komplexe sehr komplexe
maschinen jedes organ erfüllt einen
bestimmten zweck
und sie sehen auch hier das ganze sind
verschiedene pfeile
also das ist der input sozusagen dass
der output das kennen sie auch bei
programmieren programmier-
angelegenheiten mit mit mit die software
maschinen oder software programmieren da
gibt es in put und es gibt ein output
seine funktionen sind eine funktion ich
setze ein wert ein und bekommen einen
wert ausgesprochen
und genauso sagt jetzt descartes nach
dem prinzip jedenfalls ohne das jetzt in
den tieren konkret zahnräder zu finden
sind aber man könnte sagen wir sind eben
sehr sehr sehr komplexe zahnräder sehr
sehr kleine feine zahnräder die wir wenn
wir nur lang genug oder gründlich genug
hinschauen irgendwann finden also in
sich ein konkretes zahnrad aber halt so
und prinzip was mechanistisch das ne das
ist ein bisschen verallgemeinern das ist
als input und output das ist diese diese
strikte determination mechanistische
determination könnte uns haben ok und
beim menschen geht es nach descartes
nicht sagt er ja also wir können der uns
den menschen nicht so vorstellen nach
diesem input output schema das
funktioniert nicht und jetzt sagt er es
gibt zwei gründe warum es nicht
funktioniert und zwei erkenntnisse zwei
kenntnis mittel woran wir das erkennen
können dass das nicht klappt erstens
könnten sie nämlich niemals worte oder
andere zeichen dadurch gebrauchen dass
sie sie zusammenstellen die tiere wie
wir es tun um anderen unsere gedanken
bekannt zu machen wenn man kann sich
zwar vorstellen dass es massiv dass eine
maschine so konstruiert ist dass die
worte und manche worte sogar bei
gelegenheit körperliche einwirkungen
hervorbringt die gewisse veränderungen
ihren organen hervorrufen wie zb das sie
berührt man sie an irgendeiner stelle
gerade nachdem fragt was man ihr
antworten will dass sie die maschine
berührt man sie an einer anderen stelle
schreibt man tt wie und ähnliches aber
man kann sich nicht vorstellen dass sie
die worte auf verschiedenen weisen
zusammen ordnet um auf die bedeutung
alles dessen was in ihrer gegenwart laut
werden mag zu antworten wie es der
stumpfsinnig
hier begegnet uns jetzt ein argument
dass wir schon bei der frage ob coco
eine sprache verfügt im engeren sinne
was wir dort schon gesehen haben was
dort schon zur sprache gekommen ist was
ist jetzt das argument warum ist nach
descartes ist nicht möglich den menschen
als maschine zu bauen damit er als
mensch gelten kann dass er verwechselt
werden könnte mit einem menschen das ist
ziemlich modernen dieser gedanke dass
sie kennen den turing test vielleicht
schon mit urin test also ab einem
bestimmten grad von komplexität können
wir nicht mehr erkennen ob ein computer
der uns gegenüber steht also die reine
ausgabe hat in ausgabe und bildschirm
und dort etwas ansprache produziert ob
dahinter ein mensch steckt oder nicht
und wenn das eben nicht mehr möglich ist
das herauszufinden dann erhaltet die
kommentierte die künstliche intelligenz
ein extrem hohen grad erreicht der mit
dem eines menschen vielleicht zu
gleichzusetzen wäre und man sagt jetzt
diese tests seitdem sei vor kurzem zeit
dass also ein nicht mehr gelungen dass
es auseinanderzuhalten
natürlich immer die frage was man jetzt
unter künstliche intelligenz versteht
aber sehen dieses dieses
gedankenexperiment bei descartes ist
sehr sehr aktuellen modell
heutzutage kann man das auf computer
beziehen
also was ist der grund jetzt ja
genau also flexibilität la ihr stichwort
er sagt hier auf verschiedene weisen
zusammen ordnet das wäre dieses syntax
es ist syntaktische moment das man jetzt
ordnet flexibilität
wer wohingegen eine maschine jede kann
sagt so konstruiert dass das die worte
und manche worte sogar bei gelegenheit
körperliche einwirkungen hervorbringt
bei gelegenheit ist also immer
anlässlich occasional input output wenn
dann wie immer reaktiv letztendlich
nicht und sie sagt auch kreative also
menschen sagte card können zeichen so
zusammensetzen das vielleicht etwas ganz
neues dabei herauskommt und sie sind
nicht abhängig von festen input output
schemata sondern frei dagegen
sie sind spontan flexibel und das könne
sagt die karts sogar der stumpfsinnige
mensch also er argumentiert für eine
qualitative differenz zwischen tier und
mensch
und setzen jetzt gibt ja noch ein
zweites also das wirklich entscheidende
diese zusammengestellt ist es so ein
taktischen und das zweite argument das
zweite mittel ist dies sollten diese
maschinen auch manches ebenso gut oder
vielleicht besser verrichten als birg
einer von uns so würden sie doch
zweifellos bei vielen anderen versagen
wodurch offen zutage tritt dass sie
nicht aus einsicht handeln sondern nur
zur folge der einrichtung ihrer organe
denn die vernunft ist ein universal
instrument das bei allen gelegenheiten
zu diensten steht während diese organe
für jede besondere handlung eine
besondere einrichtung zu dürfen was es
unwahrscheinlich macht dass es in einer
einzigen maschine genügend verschiedene
organe gibt das in allen lebens fällen
so handeln diesen wie uns unsere
vernunft handeln lässt das ist auch ein
sehr interessantes argument weil jetzt
hier zum ersten mal die rationalität
genauer bestimmt hat also die frage wäre
jetzt die wir uns jetzt hier überlegen
müssen welche rolle welche funktion
übernimmt die vernunft inwiefern kann
die e card die vernunft ein universal
instrument nennen was wiederum auf sich
ist die vernunft ein organ wie jedes
andere
ja also wie diese organe die zu einer
bestimmten handlung dienen
offensichtlich nicht wie hat man sich
dann die verlust als ein universal
instrument oder universal organ
vorzustellen haben sie eine idee was ist
das argument
man könnte jetzt sagen die vernunft hier
ist eigentlich das geistige im engeren
sinn das ist der geist ist
wahrscheinlich ratio im lateinischen
müsst ihr noch mal nachschauen ratio
könnte warum ihn zu zahlen
gut genau die vernunft nicht auf
derselben ebene angeordnet wie die
anderen organe ist also nicht noch ein
zusätzliches organ was in zutritt zur
additiv was wir für einen bestimmten
zweck dient sondern es ist darüber
stehen
man könnte auch sagen es eine form ist
eine form die flexibel spontan in allen
lebens fällen allen möglichen fällen die
organe so konfiguriert dass sie
angewiesen ist also nicht so dass der
mensch jetzt für jede mögliche situation
ein eigenes organ hat sondern hat eine
begrenzte anzahl von organen die unter
umständen identisch mit derjenigen ist
die auch tiere besitzen sie sehen ja der
mensch hat eigentlich dieselben organe
also säugetiere haben eigentlich
dieselben organe herz lunge und milz
leber usw hände oder letztendlich toten
und da fängt sein aber schon an die
hände sind natürlich extrem
differenziert diese diese abonnierbare
daumen ist ja noch so ein kriterium der
den menschen von affen unterscheidet
deswegen auch die begreifbar kite besser
ist wenn man kann also besser begreifen
wenn man die daumen also wenn man den
daumen gegenüber setzen kann den fingern
das ist wohl auch so typisch menschliche
eigenschaft aber ansonsten vielleicht
alle organe ziemlich ähnlich und das
argument ist es sind nicht die organe
also die den menschen vom tier
unterscheiden sondern es ist die
mögliche konfiguration die mögliche form
in die diese organe treten können und
die sie der vernunft verdanken also die
formbarkeit die flexibilität der organe
die nach descartes den menschen vom tier
unterscheidet während beim tier
dieselben organe relativ starr nur auf
spezielle ziele gerichtet sind
das ist so das argument wie mir scheint
von descartes halten sie das für
plausibel
genau das ist jetzt erst mal so
dahingestellt
wichtig ist es erst mal nur mit esel
sind aber es ist glaube ich als modell
mal wie mir scheint erstmal eine
interessante these weil er möglichen
grund dafür angeht warum bei gleicher
organische konstitution also wesentlich
eigentlich identische konstitution
dieselben organe finden wir bei den
säugetieren auch warum dennoch beim
menschen höhere flexibilität gegeben
sein kann wenn wir so was wie eine
universal vernunft annehmen
die ist natürlich noch nicht bewiesen
sie würde jetzt mal angenommen werden
das wäre ein möglicher grund der diese
flexibilität von der im vorherigen zitat
gesprochen hatte erklären kann
das wäre dieses universal organ was
nicht schematisch wie diese ente die sie
da gesehen hat auf input output
mechanismen reagiert sondern die
flexibel reagieren können und dazu eben
nicht unendlich viele organe braucht für
jede situation ein neues organ sondern
mit einer begrenzten mit dem begrenzten
repertoire an organen unbegrenzt viel
machen kann
das ist letztendlich dasselbe prinzip
wie wenn sie mal überlegen sie haben
einen begrenzten zeichen wortschatz ein
zeichen schatz wir haben das alphabet
hat grenzt anzahl von zeichen und sie
können mit diesen zeichen durch
kombination eigentlich unendlich viel
bin unendlich viel ausdrücken dass
komposition ali teetz prinzip sie können
beliebig zusammensetzen neu
konfigurieren
trotz begrenzten zeichen elementen und
das scheint ein spezifikum der sprache
zu sein
das scheint aber auch jetzt hier bezogen
auf die vernunft spezifisch rationales
eine rationale eigenschaft zu sein
diese flexibilität da jetzt in
interessanten punkt gefunden den wir mal
weiter verfolgen wollen
jetzt geht es weiter diese zwei mittel
kennzeichen nun auch den unterschied
zwischen mensch und tier
denn es ist ganz auffällig dass es
keinen so stumpfsinnigen und dummen
menschen gibt nicht einmal einen
verrückten ausgenommen der nicht fähig
wäre verschiedene worte zusammen zu
ordnen und daraus eine rede aufzubauen
mit der er seine gedanken verständlich
machen und dass es im gegenteil kein
anderes tier gibt so verkommen und
glücklich veranlagt ist sein mag dass
ähnliches leistet dies liegt nicht daran
dass den tieren organ dazu fehlten
denn man kann beobachten dass specht den
papageien ebenso wie wir worte
hervorbringen können und dass sie
dennoch nicht reden das heißt zu
erkennen geben können dass sie denken
und was sie sagen wie wir von geburt
taubstumme menschen dagegen müssen die
organe die andere zum reden gebrauchen
ebenso oder mehr noch entbehren als die
tiere und er finden doch für gewöhnlich
selbst zeichen mit denen sie sich leuten
ihre gewohnten umgebung die zeit haben
ihre sprache zu lernen verständlich
machen
dies zeigt nicht bloß dass tiere weniger
verstand haben als menschen sondern
vielmehr dass sie gar keinen haben denn
es ist offenkundig dass nur sehr wenig
verstand braucht um reden zu können
und weil man ja bemerkt dass die tiere
derselben art ebenso sehr verschieden
sind wie die menschen und dass einige
sich leichter dressieren lassen als
andere
so ist es kaum glaublich dass ein affe
oder papagei der in seiner art der
vollkommenste sein mag nicht wenigstens
darin einem der dümmsten kinder oder
mindestens ein kind das nicht ganz bei
sinnen ist gleichen würde wenn seine
seele nicht von ganz anderer grund
beschaffenheit wäre als die unsere das
ist jetzt schon eine starke these
weil er sagt hier das gar keinen namen
dass sie sie haben nicht nur weniger
verstand als menschen sondern sie haben
gar keinen
und das ist schon eine starke these und
sie hatten ja vor das beispiel diese
krähen gebracht und jetzt kann man sich
wirklich fragt ist das wirklich nur
maschinell ist es als ist es bei green
nur input output immer überlegen sie mal
was spricht dagegen tränen so eine karte
sische verfassung zu unterstellen ich
hätte jetzt zum beispiel würde sofort
und beispiel an einfallen was gegen die
karts sprechen könnte also stichpunkt
flexibilität verstand vernunft bedeutet
flexibilität und nichts starres input
output schema befolgen von input output
schemata was könnte man jetzt gegen die
karts anführen mit beispiel auf die
krähen um das sagen nein so stark ist
dieser mechanismus nicht sie hatten sich
gemeldet
genau
genau also mein autobahnen gab es früher
noch nicht vielleicht haben krähen vor
500 jahren die nüsse auf straßen fallen
lassen in der hoffnung das warten also
jeder wagen drüberfahren oder pferde mit
ihren hufen darauf treten aber vor 3000
jahren oder 5.000 oder 10.000 jahren
wird diese möglichkeit nicht gegeben
haben da werden andere mittel gesucht
haben
also ich glaube dass es durchaus guter
beleg dafür dass diese these von
descartes sehr problematisch ist aber
wird durchaus bei tieren eine gewisse
flexibilität finden sich an bestimmte
gegebenheiten anzupassen und das auf
eine kreative weise zu tun
also das ist eine starke teams
ja das muss man sich überlegen ich meine
sie haben ja gesehen anhand dieser zwei
erkenntnis mittel die die karte uns
gegeben hat das erste war flexibilität
der sprache kreativität kombinatorik der
sprachen das zweite war vernunft als
universal instrument unserer organe
beliebig anzuordnen
als der vernunft und sprache wären nach
descartes gleich strukturiert weil sie
flexibilität und unabhängigkeit
ermöglichen sagt ist eine struktur
gleichheit die zwischen vernunft und
sprache herrschen man müsste jetzt eben
genauer bei krems hinschauen ob die wie
die kommunizieren ich kenne mich da
nicht aus sie haben gemeint es sei nicht
so bekannt bei denen ja das mag eben
unser vorkommen ich weiß jetzt auch
nicht aber da könnte man mal sich
vielleicht schicke ich mal was rum über
die neueste krähen forschung erklären
sind ja sehr intelligente tiere und ich
würde das erstaunen wenn sie nicht auch
eine komplexe kommunikation komplexes
kommunikationsmedium hätten
ob es nun ob man sitzt sprachen kann sei
dahingestellt wir haben gesagt es gibt
eine enge und weiten sprach begriffen in
engeren sprach begriff obwohl diese
flexibilität der instrumentellen
vernunft diese müsse auf die straße zu
werfen um damit eben dann nach
überfahren den inhalt zu fressen
nahelegen würde dass da auch eine
komplexe sprache zu grunde liegt das
würde ich mich ich schaue gerne mal nach
und schickt ihn mal so ein paar
forschungsergebnissen als ich mich würde
es wundern wenn ich auch eine komplexe
kommunikationsform dort vorhanden wäre
aber ob man es dann im engeren sinne
sprachen den qantas bleibt jedenfalls
offen weil doch wie ich schon sagte
dieses nutzt beispiel nur das
vorhandensein einer instrumentellen
vernunft nahelegt instrumentelle
vernunft als mittel zum zweck immer
mittel zweck relation und die vernunft
vermag natürlich auch noch anderes als
nur in mittelzell relation zu denken
zum beispiel nach kant wie wir bestimmt
noch sehen werden so was wie moralität
werte normen als solche zu erkennen das
ist nach der meinung vieler philosophen
auch eine leistung der vernunft das ist
dann nicht nur mehr instrumentell mittel
zweck sondern das ist absolut und das
ist sicherlich ein aspekt der vernunft
der trainier fehlen wird während enger
vernunft begriff
sie bringen mich dann auch in anderen
guten punkt ein kommilitone hatte
vorgeschlagen dass wir schopenhauer auch
noch einbeziehen
ich habe diesen text den wir verwenden
könnten auf lsf system gestellt da
finden sie den und alle weiteren
informationen
also könnt gerne auch ein essay über
schopenhauers sprachverständnis oder
tier verständnis schreiben ja es war da
hinten noch eine millionärin
ja das ist eine gute frage was sagen die
anderen teilnehmer dazu also das wäre
jetzt ja dann ein hirnorganische defekte
also bestimmte region des gehirns
aufgrund eines unfalls eingeschränkt
sind wenn da die neuronalen
verknüpfungen nicht mehr existieren oder
nur sehr sehr schwach existieren werde
es einen grund die menschen vernunft
abzusprechen
ja
ich habs gerade nicht verstanden weil ja
ich meinen sie hätten ist daneben
potenziell schon aber aktuell eben nicht
also es geht es um die aktuelle aktuelle
frage wenn jetzt dieses diese region
geschädigt ist für diesen moment
faktisch ist da noch vernunft
was könnte man sagen ja
aber das wäre doch gerade so ein
argument für die intelligenz oder für
die bewahrung der menschlichkeit wenn
man sich eben nicht mehr verbal
artikulieren kann sondern eben über
gesten oder so ne oder der mensch könnte
vielleicht was schreiben wenn ihm nur
das sprachvermögen fehlen das motorische
zentrum wäre noch intakt und ein
weiteres möglichkeit wäre ich will nicht
zu sehr vorweg greifen dass eine region
des gehirns diese region ersetzt es gibt
ja solche phänomene ich kenne mich da
jetzt im einzelnen aus aber das gehirn
kann erstaunlich viel übernehmen was
ausgefallenes war da noch andere
meldungen hier ja
das wahlsystem ische einschränkungen
weil da war noch eine meldung bei ihnen
ja
ja richtig ich glaub ja also ich glaube
nicht dass man so auch nicht dass man zu
eng fassen müsse es eine spannende frage
ob denken nicht immer sprachlich
verfasst sein muss wie genau sprachen
denkt das eingespannte frage er sind
ganz hinten ganz
hmm
ja interessant der punkt jetzt hatten
sie sich noch immer eine gute frage die
ich auch noch thematisieren wollte das
setzt natürlich einverständnis des
gehirns voraus und mir scheint dass die
neuere forschung immer mehr zeigt dass
das gehirn eben nicht modular aufgebaut
ist baukasten mäßig sondern netzwerk
mäßig netzwerk mäßig sehr flexibel
manche regionen können andere die
funktion anderer übernehmen ist ein ganz
ganz komplexes netzwerk was man nicht
als additives sagen baukastensystem wohl
verstehen kann
genau es gibt wohl sehr komplexe
wechselwirkung richtig aber auch eine
flexibilität hohe flexibilität
das ist jetzt eine spannende frage der
philosophie des geistes also wie geist
mentale eigenschaften wie
selbstbewusstsein wie sprachliches
vermögen wie qualia mit den herrn
organische struktur zusammenhängen also
es ist sicherlich so dass wenn wir einen
teil ausschalten oder beeinflussen des
gehirns dass eine auswirkung hat auf
mentale qualität aber es ist damit nicht
gesagt dass das mentale in seiner
phänomenalen struktur in seinem
festgehalt aus der neuronalen struktur
erklärbar ist oder verstehbar
verständlich wird also das ist die frage
des reduktionismus natürlich hängen
unsere mentalen phänomene mit der
hirnorganischen struktur zusammen weil
wenn wir dort eingreifen sich die
mentalen phänomene ändern also wenn adam
w aber das heißt nicht dass eben diese
konkreten gehalten daraus irgendwie
verständlich werden in ihrer in ihrem
gehalten wir können nicht diese dieses
quale des schmerzes richtig verstehen in
seiner qualität wenn wir es auf die
reizung von c fasern zurückführen
die heizung von c fasern und der
phänomenale eindruck von schmerzen sind
einfach zwei völlig verschiedene dinge
die reizung der c fasern führt zum
qualen des schmerzes also kausale kausal
relation aber halt nicht eine identität
denn es ist nicht dasselbe
und das ist das problem das ist man also
die mentalen so eine eigenständige
realität schon irgendwie zu sprechen
muss phänomenal
auch wenn sie abhängig ist auf eine
bestimmte kausale weise vom hirn vom
gehirn
das gehirn ist was ganz komplexes und
ich denke die struktur des gehirns diese
dieses netzwerk system ist so ein
hinweisen dass descartes mit dieser
flexibilität schon guten punkt getroffen
hat das gehirn als komplexes netzwerk
ist extrem flexibel extrem und darin ist
es strukturell analog zur verfasstheit
der sprache und zur festzeit dessen was
er diese das universal instrumenten
nimmt das gehirn ist eben so komplex
dass es uns uns organe auf unglaublich
verschiedene weisen flexibel einsetzen
lässt
wichtig bei descartes ist es natürlich
noch anderes nach descartes hat ja diese
zwei substanzen lehre die res extender
die ausgedehnte substanz als der körper
der körper die körper maschine sozusagen
und er hat noch die disco getanzt das
wäre dann die denkende substanz und
beide sind völlig getrennt voneinander
und dieses beispiel im gehirn wäre jetzt
nicht die karts auffassung genau richtig
der verstand ist irgendwie vorgeordnet
er ist sozusagen der der regler der
regelt alles
der schwebt darüber und das ist
natürlich ein problem bei descartes weil
er sagt die res koki tanz die denkende
substanz ist vom körperlichen
vollständig getrennt dann muss man sich
fragen wie beide interagieren wie kann
denn wenn beide so verschieden sind
denken oder vernunft und körper
organismus wie kann denn dann das denken
einfluss nehmen auf den körper und
kausal verursachen dass wir zum beispiel
die hand heben
da muss doch irgendeine verbindung
zwischen dem mentalen und dem
körperlichen existieren und welche art
ist das und braucht man da nicht noch
was drittes was vermittelt es was die
beziehung erst überhaupt ermöglicht
ich denke sie haben den richtigen punkt
getroffen also die card hat da so ein
ausschließbar kriterium nur menschen
haben die red ants natürlich auch noch
gott ist die reine disco getanzt und das
mag auch noch andere gestalten geben
personen geben weiß nicht engel optik
hat jetzt mit engeln noch argumentiert
mir ist das nicht bekannt aber es wäre
möglich dass es außer menschen noch
andere wesen gebe die eine gedenken die
substanz verfügen
aber wie sie richtig sagen er hat so
eine ganz ganz starke opposition ganz
strikte trennung bei tieren kommt so war
es nicht vor dass mitteilung das halte
ich natürlich wie auch fehler die
allermeisten für hochproblematisch weil
wir jetzt im falle der krähen gesehen
haben durchaus eine flexible
rationalität gegeben ist es ist immer
die frage besteht zwischen mensch und
tier ein qualitativer unterschied oder
ein kategorischer unterschied von
rationalität also tiere haben gar keine
universal vernunft oder haben sie eine
form von rationalität die eben nicht so
hoch stufig ist wie diejenige die wir
haben oder ist es eine rationalität von
andere qualität als quantität qualität
geht es ganz verschiedene möglichkeiten
also wir können sicherlich heutzutage
nicht mehr sagen dass sie ihre gar keine
rationalität haben das wäre sicherlich
falsch nach heutigen erkenntnissen
da ist eine form von rationalität
vorhanden jetzt stellt sich die frage
ist es nur eine quantitativ nieder
stufige reform von rationalität oder ist
es eine qualitativ verschiedene form von
ratsmitglied das ist die entscheidende
frage also man könnte jetzt sagen
tiere sind halt nicht ganz so
intelligente auf einem spektrum tiere
haben jetzt nur ein iq von maximal nicht
70 oder 80
man sagt ja manche sagen coco hätten iq
von 80 gehabt
da ist die frage ob der ico eben auch
rationalität in ihrer ganzen bandbreite
überhaupt erfassen kann das kann sie
kann nicht der intelligenzquotient oder
ob man sagt menschliche rationalität ist
selbst wenn der iq niedrig ist wie es
die karte zeigt immer noch ganz was
anderes das was völlig anderes weiter
irgendwie immer noch eine ganz andere
form von spontanität reflexivität
gegeben ist oder weil vielleicht könnte
man mit anderen worten sagen eine form
von wertebewusstsein da es ein
mobilitäts bewusstsein normativität
bewusstsein wird dass tiere nicht
verfügen das entspannte fragen also die
frage ist die sind tiere von menschen
hinsichtlich ihrer vernunft nur
quantitativ sondern bestimmte grad
verschieden oder qualitativ das ist die
spannende war noch die meldung habe ich
noch jemanden übersehen der das etwas
sagen wollte also mir scheint dass
dickhardt guten punkt jedenfalls
getroffen hat wenn er auf diese
flexibilität investieren weitere ist
weiter vorstellungen
[Musik]
richtig genau das ist auch ein punkt der
gegen descartes spricht die karts
scheint alle tiere in einen topf zu
werfen
es sind alles maschinen sind input
output maschinen enden oder wahl fische
oder als wale oder coco der affe coco
wäre auch so ne input output maschine
ohne mikro wäre auch eine input output
maschinen und das ist wohl eher
unplausibel also es scheint nachzulegen
auch zwischen ihnen innerhalb des
tierreichs verschiedene stufen
festzumachen eine graduelle oder sogar
vielleicht qualitative skala von
rationalität anzusetzen wo nach oben
krähen besonders hoch besonders
intelligente tiere sind und natürlich
ameisen und so mein ameisen sind ebenso
wohl wie wir in diesen text gelesen
haben zur einführung eben doch sehr sehr
stark determiniert ne das haben an
diesem einführungstext von wild am und
perla ist der tiere behandelt also
ameisen kann man wohl keine sprache zu
sprechen
das sind ganz starke kommunikations
schemata die auf reize reagieren und es
war das beispiel das dass man meinte
ameisen würden also tote art genossen
durch komplexe form von kommunikation
dann heraus transportieren um hat
nachgewiesen dass das nur auf basis
eines botenstoffs funktioniert wenn man
diesen duftstoffe diesen signalstoff auf
irgendwelche andere tiere träufelt
irgendwelche käfer dann tragen die dann
auch weg das ist ein praktisch nur
diesen botenstoffen das ist dieses
dieses reiz reaktions schema
ja das ist eine faszinierende form der
kommunikation aber eben immer noch sehr
stark reiz reaktions mäßig verfassten
wenn man jetzt in seine künstliche laufe
daher stellen würde wo auch geklopft
wird dann würden die eben dass da so
natürlich reagieren nach diesem schema
müsste eben die flexibilität der tiere
prüfen müsste experimente machen und
schauen ist es wirklich so ein starres
reiz reaktions schimmer oder sind in der
lage flexibel zu reagieren wie es nikkei
kann
die muss auf eine befahrene straße
dürfen das ist gar nicht in diesem code
drin sind da muss die krähe wirklich
offentlich nachdenken und ein paar
gedanken schritte vorziehen
und ich glaube auch dass es also doch
nahe liegt zu sagen es gibt verschiedene
intelligente tiere zu verschiedenen
leistungen in der lage sind und es gibt
weniger und höher
intelligente tiere natürlich bleibt die
frage offen ob dies intelligent selbst
der höchsten tiere nur eine niedere form
nieder gerade form von rationalität ist
oder ob es einfach qualitativ von
unserer intelligenz verschieden ist das
ist die spannende frage weiteres zitat
auch darf man die worte nicht mit den
natürlichen lebensweise rungen
verwechseln die innere erregungen der
tiere zu erkennen geben und die von
maschinen ebenso gut nachgeahmt werden
können wie von tieren oder denken wie
einige alte weil die antiken dass die
tiere zwar reden aber ihre sprache nicht
verstehen wir aber ihre sprache nicht
verstehen denn wenn das wahr wäre so
hätten sie sich zumal ja viele ihrer
organe den unseren entsprechen uns
ebenso gut verständlich machen können
wie ihresgleichen
es ist auch sehr bemerkenswert dass zwar
viele tiere in manchen ihrer handlungen
mehr geschicklichkeit zeit als wir
dass man aber trotzdem dieselben tiere
in vielen anderen fällen überhaupt keine
zeigen sie der tatbestand also dass sie
es besser machen als wir
er weiß nicht dass ich angst haben
denn wenn man es so nimmt hätten sie
mehr als irgendeiner von uns und würden
ist in jeder beziehung besser machen
aber sie haben im gegenteil gar keinen
und es ist die natur die in ihnen je
nach der einrichtung ihrer organe wirkt
ebenso wie offensichtlich eine uhr nur
ausreden und federn gebaut ist genauer
die stunden zählen und die zeit messen
kann als wir mit all unserer klugheit
das ist auch ein sehr interessantes
argument hier kann es noch mal in
eigenen worten re formulieren was ist
der grund dafür dass tiere selbst wenn
sie mehr geschicklichkeit zeigen als wir
dennoch nicht mehr genutzt haben als wir
nach descartes jetzt
ja
genau also die besondere ausbildung
manche eigenschaften die uns in unserer
ausbildung überlegen ist heißt nicht
dass da mehr geist im hintergrund steht
es ist einfach eine bessere anpassung an
bestimmte situation ganz enger focus
gerade mit flexibel sein hochgradigen
spezialisierung zum beispiel sehen
manche tiere viel besser als wir
der radler adleraugen die sehen aus ich
weiß nicht wie viele hundert metern
sehen die noch ne ne maus im gras das
organ das sehvermögen ist und zum viel
überlegen
dennoch können wir dank gps und
sonstigen modernen medien viel besser
sehen wir könnten in irgend einer
absehbaren zukunft vom mond aus einem
aus auf einer beliebigen wiese erkennen
müssen die technik einfach noch
extrapolieren in 20 jahren ist es
möglich mittels unseren technischen
verfahren eine maus vom mond aus zu
identifizieren also wir haben viel
schlechtere augen aber durch die
flexibilität des einsatzes unserer
organe können wir instrumente bauen das
ist auch noch ein punkt in die karte
jetzt hier interessanterweise nicht an
bringt instrumente oder prothesen also
zusätzliche organe schaffen das ist ein
wichtiger punkt den er hier jetzt nicht
diskutiert wir haben nur eine begrenzte
anzahl von organen aber durch die
flexible anordnung uns organe dank war
vernunft können wir zusätzliche organe
oder besser gesagt instrumente bauen die
uns unsere begrenztheit der organe eben
ausgleichen oder sogar versteigern lässt
wie zb irgendwie eine super kamera die
vom mond eben aus super verlor die das
vom mond aus bestimmte kleine objekte
sichtbar werden lässt
ich habe es gar nicht verstanden was
meinen sie damit genau richtig genau
oder denken sie an flugzeug wir können
nicht fliegen aber wie also wir können
selbst nicht fliegen aber wir können
eben solche geräte bauen wir können uns
so ein düsenantrieb auf den rücken
schnallen oder sonstige dinge erfinden
die uns in absehbarer zeit so flexibel
agieren lassen als ob wir flügel hätten
das ist nur eine frage der zeit bis wir
so tolle triebwerke erfinden die uns
hier sofort abheben lassen
also ich wurde dass die karte jetzt hier
nicht vermisst form von instrument
spricht das ist wohl ein punkt der nicht
ins im blick hatte sie erst noch
interessieren
genau richtig das ist ist gut genau das
ist also die these des mängelwesen sie
kennen alle diese anthropologen und
arnold gehlen und helmuth plessner aus
dieser zeit kommt dieser begriff des
meldewesens ist aber sicherlich schon
ältere gedanke dass man also die
schwächen kompensieren also die
natürliche begrenztheit wird durch die
vernunft kompensiert
aber wie sie richtig sagen ist das
teilweise auch bei manchen tieren
festzustellen wie zum beispiel bei dpa
die jetzt ihren schnabel ich weiß nicht
ob eine creme mit ihrem schnabel eine
nuss knacken könnte ich glaube nicht ich
glaube nicht mehr dass heißt auch da
wird dann improvisiert aber natürlich
baut sich die krieg ein instrument aber
der fisch ein bisschen der affe nimmt
dann ein stock es gibt ja da experimente
und also ein verlängerter arm sozusagen
um dann irgendwie ein objekt im käfig
oder außerhalb des käfigs hereinzuholen
dann nimmt er sich einen stock damit ob
das jetzt aber schon ein instrument ist
im basalen sind ist sicherlich aber er
müsste nach meinem begriffen damit man
das instrument im starken sie nennt sich
aus verschiedenen teilen wieder
stichwort flexibilität aus verschiedenen
bestandteilen sich ein instrument
zusammensetzen kombinatorische das ist
sicherlich möglich also ich möchte nicht
ausschließen dass das möglich ist
das ist jetzt eine andere frage mit dem
nestbau also da sagen wohl viele dass
das ganz klar reiz reaktions schema ist
also das ist ganz klar der genetisch
also determiniert wenn diese
wetterbedingungen herrschen diese
jahreszeit eintritt dann wird dieser
mechanismus in gang gesetzt natürlich
muss dann der vogel sah man sich
überlegen wobei es am besten aber das
ist so ein eingeimpft instinkt dass dass
er das schon weiß oder zum beispiel ich
habe sie nicht vergessen
ich habe jetzt beobachtet vor kurzem wie
eine weste jetzt alles so schönes wetter
war von einem alten holztisch wirklich
fasern abgenagt hat also hat es richtig
gehört wie sie mit ihren kiefer
werkzeugen und werkzeugen das also
abgehakt hat und dann woanders hin
geflogen ist hat es mit dem speichern
vermischt und dann wird es so zusammen
klebstoff und bauen die sich da ihr nest
und so das ist also wohl ziemlich
ziemlich determiniert aber dem apfel und
mit diesem stock da gibt es schon
ziemlich in richtung instrument
nicht mehr
wenn ich das nicht auf jeden fall also
ich meine es ist wichtig dass man wie
sie richtig sagen unterscheidet zwischen
einem konkreten menschen und der
menschheit als wir sprechen immer von
der tier hat oder von der spezialist der
der krähen oder was auch immer und von
der menschheit also nicht von einzelnen
individuen aber die menschheit ist eben
der lage teleskope zu bauen und ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob es die die gorilla
hyde
ob die dazu in der lage wäre
diese richtung wäre dann doch dieser
einzelne menschen nimmt und sich an
einer spezies zu orten diese summe
könnte ja man könnte dann aber sagen die
der mensch hat es potenziell das war das
argument vor hin und sagen der mensch
hat potenziell auch wenn er jetzt
aufgrund von krankheit oder ich weiß
nicht sonstigen defekten eben nicht
diese intelligent diese normale
intelligenz entwickelt in sich die
möglichkeit komplexe instrumente zu
bauen
da braucht man nicht in die kuh von 130
sondern da reicht ein guter iq
das hat
dazu erreicht
ich weiß es nicht also wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel die dna schaut ja dass das
ist richtig also die potenzielle täter
davon das ist ein wichtiger punkt die
potenzielle darf man nicht so
überstrapazieren
weil dann natürlich im urknall alles
angelegt ist ja also man muss wenn man
vom potenzial i tät spricht immer eine
starke regionale potenzial i tät im
blick nehmen also konkret richtet auf
was und dann kann man das sehr einfach
mit den anzeigen mit der dna mit dem mit
dem mit dem vermögen was da angelegt ist
um der wurm hat es einfach nicht in der
dna drin natürlich wenn man die
potentially tät wie sie richtig sagen
weiter also extrapolieren zurückführt
dann ist alles irgendwie abhängig im
sinne der möglichkeit dann hat der
urknall potenziell enthalten dass wir
jetzt hier alles sitzen eingeschlossen
als ein weiterer punkt
also ein wichtiger punkt ist auch noch
die gesellschaft ist richtig die haben
jetzt noch gar nicht so eilig genommen
weil wir jetzt hier sehr vom individuum
immer ausgehen das hat man zwei
meldungen erst dann sie
diese weise auch noch heuer sozialität
gemessen ob die menschen ein
interessanter punkt
ja
wir verstehen noch nicht
das klingt so als würde er
als würden sie die karts zustimmen
tendenziell ja von dieser universal
vernunft der spricht also spannendes
ding alles geht läuft wohl auf diese
flexibilität hinaus wir brauchen um
geist auch im engeren sinne
zuzuschreiben erholt geraten hohen
gerade an spontanität reflexivität und
kreativität anhand von bestimmten
situationen die uns eben erkennen lassen
dass es hier nicht nur um reiz reaktions
schimmer sich handelt ich glaube das
haben wir jetzt glaube ich recht gut
herausgearbeitet diese flexibilität man
kann das dann auch mit anderen worten
noch freiheit nehmen ich bin jetzt aber
sehr vorsichtig diesen sehr sehr starken
und metaphysisch aufgeladen begriff der
freiheit hier einzuführende möglich
möglichst außen vor lassen weil
natürlich hat etwas mit freiheit zu tun
wenn man flexibel auf neue situationen
reagiert aber das braucht wir brauchen
ein begriff der freiheit nicht wir
können solche phänomene mit dem begriff
der rationalität sehr gut erklären weil
er auch intelligenz immer auch die
fähigkeiten ist wie man in bestimmten
situationen sich an die gegebenen
herausforderungen anpasst damit auf
reagiert also freiheit brauchen nicht
aber das schwebt so im hintergrund der
freiheitsbegriff jetzt gehen wir noch
mal ein bisschen weiter weil ich noch
auf montag ein bisschen eingehen möchte
in dieser sitzung es geht weiter mit dem
kart so dann hatte ich die vernünftige
seele beschrieben und gezeigt dass sie
keineswegs aus den bewegenden kräften
der materie abgeleitet werden kann wie
die übrigen dinge die ich gesprochen
hatte sondern durch einen besonderen art
geschaffen sein muss und wieso es nicht
genügt dass sie im menschlichen körper
wie der kapitän an bord seines schiffes
wohnt außer vielleicht um die glieder
des menschlichen körpers zu bewegen sind
dass sie enger mit ihm verbunden und
vereinigt sein müsse um außerdem
ähnliche gefühle und begeben zu haben
wie wir
und so ein wirklicher mensch zu sein
schließlich habe ich mich an dieser
stelle ein wenig mehr über das thema der
seele verbreitet da diese wichtigsten
themen überhaupt gehört denn nach dem
irrtum der gottes leute die ich oben
glaube hinreichend widerlegt zu haben
gibt es keinen der schwache geister mehr
vom geraden weg der tugend abbringen als
die einbildung tier seelen hätten die
gleiche natur wie menschen sehen und wir
hätten folglich nach diesen lieben
wieder etwas zu fürchten
noch etwas zu hoffen genauso wenig wie
die fliegen und die ameisen stattdessen
begreift man wenn man weiß wie groß der
unterschied ist die gründe viel besser
beweisen dass unsere seele ihrer natur
nach verkommen und unabhängig vom leibe
und folglich nicht mit ihm zu sterben
bestimmt ist und wird alsdann zumal man
ja keine andere ursache ihrer zerstörung
findet dadurch natürlicherweise auf den
schluss geführt dass sie unsterblich ist
ja auch noch ein spannendes thema wenn
tiere seelen haben sind diese seelen
dann auch unsterblich wenn man von sowas
die unsterblichkeit der seele ausgeht
wenn man sagt die seele ist nichts
materielles dann unterliegt sie nicht
den gesetzen des vergehens und
entstehens desjenigen das material ist
ist als einer anderen zeit logik
unterworfen ist nicht zeitlich verfasst
vielleicht daraus würde dann folgen das
unsterblich ist er wie sieht's mit ihren
haustieren sie doch auch lebendig und
viele würden sagen beseelt sind ihren
auch unsterblich da kommt man also sehr
schnell in ganz schwierige theologische
komplikationen das mag auch ein grund
sein warum die karts ihren ungern eine
seele seines kapitals zu spricht weil
sie eben dann auch unsterblich sein
müssten das nun mal noch so dahin
gestellt das hat auch durchaus
theologische implikationen moral
philosophische auch noch
wir sind jetzt bis jetzt nur auf die
erkenntnistheoretischen ontologischen
und rationalität theoretischen dimension
eingegangen die ganze moralische debatte
fehlt noch bis jetzt ganz hinten
ja also bei descartes ist seele und 15
eng zusammen verwogen miteinander
verwoben also es ist eben ein sicherlich
einerseits ein lebensprinzip und da wäre
man jetzt geneigt das in allem
lebendigen anzusetzen wenn sie mal an
aristoteles denken die an ihm er ist
alles kennt bestimmte stufen der seele
es gibt die lehrsäle die auf pflanzen
haben weil sie organisch verfasst sind
es gibt die wahrnehmen die seele das
wären dann tiere und es gibt dann auch
intellektuelle seele der intellektuelle
serienteile intellektuelle zählen stufe
wieder an uns betrifft die card ist sehr
gegen auf aristoteles gerichtet also
seine verwendung von seele ist vielmehr
auf diesen rationalen zählen begriff
konzentrierten und wenn er auch von
unsterblichkeit der seele spricht wird
es auch sehr klar weil er würde
sicherlich bestreiten dass pflanzen
unsterblich sind irgendwie also da ist
ganz klar ein trennung zu aristoteles
sehen begriff der viel weiter ist als
derjenige von descartes hat ein sehr
sehr engen seelen begriff wir sehr eng
mit der estoque tanz verbunden ist ich
würde es jetzt nicht gleich
identifizieren aber es ist sehr enger zu
enger bezug
richtig richtig ja wichtig organ oder
organon organist werkzeug ein organ ist
ein werkzeug das ist richtig also jedes
jedes lebendige wesen ist eigentlich ein
werkzeug ist werkzeug haft verfasst oder
hat werkzeuge die hände oder den
schnabel jetzt sie bei dieser ente aber
mit instrument könnte man eben auch noch
meinen die zu erfinden entwickelnden
instrumente die unsere mängel als
mängelwesen ausgleichen also dass man
sich an ein zweiter menschen zu zeigen
gebaut oder sich transformiert
angesichts neuer herausforderungen und
das wäre dann doch ein ganz klares
beispiel dafür dass der mensch sehr
flexibel ist also wirklich aus diesem
mangel an sich durch seine kreativität
seine vernunft seine fantasie eben viel
besser anpassen kann an andere an
bestimmte lebensumstände als ist ihre
können das wäre ein mögliches argument
hmm
ja
dessen guter punkt genau wie verstehen
sie das ja also spannende frage das
betrifft auch wieder die frage von
vorhin wie genaue seele und rees koki
tanz miteinander verwandt das ist also
sehr exklusiver begriff der jetzt nicht
nur das hotel ischen sinne so weit
gefasst ist dass es damit nur das
belebende prinzip meint die karts sagt
wir müssen immer diesen test machen
könnten nicht pflanzen klose maschinen
sagen nach input output schemata
funktionieren und könnten wir da
prinzipiell eine beseelte pflanze und
eine maschinelle pflanze nicht mehr
unterscheiden
und wenn diese möglichkeit geben ist
dass wir beide nicht mehr unterscheiden
können oder auch ein tier was eine
maschine ist dann ist es letztendlich
für ihn ein hinweis dass da keine seele
eigentlich vorhanden ist die sind so
wenn wir im gedankenexperiment annehmen
können dass es eine maschine müssen beim
menschen sagt eckardt ist es nicht
möglich zu imaginieren als sich
vorzustellen dass er eine maschine wäre
weil ebenso flexibel reagieren kann
bestimmte situation und deswegen ist
darin so eine art von denk notwendigkeit
angelegt dass wir davon ausgehen müssen
dass der mensch eben eine seele hat oder
eine rationale seele hat die unabhängig
vom leib gerissen
also sehen sind spannende fragen hier
und jetzt wollen wir noch am ende
unserer sitzung etwas auf michele de
monterrey eingehen auf eine
schutzschrift
die in einer edition entnommen worden
ist die ursprünglich im jahr 1753
erschienen und es werden sie bestimmt
schon gemerkt haben dass die sprache
etwas altertümlich altertümlich wirkt
lassen sie sich davon nicht irritieren
manche wörter verwerten wir heutzutage
nicht mehr so aber im grossen ganzen ist
es verständlich und auch hier wollen wir
wieder fragen wie wie fern diese theorie
überzeugend ist und vor allem wie jetzt
montani argumente vorbringt die den die
wir jetzt bei der kart kennengelernt
haben entgegen stehen also montani
setzte gegenpart sozusagen nimmt die
andere seite dieser debatte ein und
argumentiert dafür dass tiere sehr wohl
über geist verfügen und er geht noch
weiter sagt tiere sind sogar noch
intelligenter als menschen alle haben
mehr vernunft als der mensch jetzt gehen
wir einfach mal ein bisschen durch er
sagte hochhuth ist ein unnatürlicher und
angeborener fehler uns menschen
der mensch ist das edelste und
gebrechliche unter allen geschöpfen
stichwort mängelwesen und dennoch ist er
das hochwertigste das arrogante das
eingebildet er merkt und sie hätten dass
er hier in dem schlamm und unrat der
welt wohnen das er an das schlechteste
lebloses zäh und träge sste teil dieses
ganzen an das unterste und von dem
himmels gewerbe am weitesten entlegene
stockwerk nebst den tieren welche von
der schlechtesten art unter den dreien
sind gebunden und angenagelt ist
nichtsdestoweniger villa sich durch
seine einbildung über den kreis des
mohns schwingen und den himmel unter
seine füße bringen
als wir sehen hier
der topos mängelwesen kommt hier auch
vor hier wird jetzt mängelwesen aber
nicht mehr als möglichkeit von
instrumentaler vernunft angesehen
sondern als bloßes defizit hier wird der
mensch eben in seiner beschränktheit
betrachtet und dem tier entgegengesetzt
und moralisierend oder moralisch sogar
problematisiert als er trotz dieses
mangels dieser mangelhaften ausstattung
das arrogantes ist natürlich portiert es
sind diese essays all das sind besonders
pointiert schriften von monterrey ist
schon eine interessante these durch eben
diese eine einbildung macht er sich
gottgleich legt sich göttliche
eigenschaften bei schneidet den tieren
seinen mitbrüdern und gesellen ihren
teil zu und gibt ihnen so viel vermögen
und kräfte als in gut denkt wie erkennt
er denn durch die stärke seines
verstandes die innerlichen und
verborgenen regierung die tiere aus was
für einer vergleichen zwischen uns und
ihnen folge der dann die dummheit der
ihn beilegen er weiß wenn ich mit meiner
katze spiele ob sie sich die zeit nicht
mehr mit mir vertreibt als ich mir diese
mit ihr vertreiben
wir treiben wechselweise miteinander
posten gleich wie ich nach gefallen
anfangen oder aufhören kann so kann sie
die katze es auch platon zählt in seiner
abbildung der güldene zeit unter dem
saturn den umgang der menschen mit den
tieren bei welchen sie sich erkundigten
belehren lesen und jeder art ihre ware
eigenschaften und charakter erfuhren
mitunter die hauptsächlich ssten vorzüge
der damaligen menschen weil sie auf
diese art eine sehr vollkommen
erkenntnis und klugheit erlangten und
daher ungemein glücklicher leben führten
als wir zu fühlen und im stand ist sid
was ist jetzt das argument hier
ja
hmm
genau das ist ja genau
genau und besonders pointiert fand ich
diese diesen satz wer weiß ob die katze
nicht mit mir dass ich die zeit
vertreiben fand ich sehr spannend
was sagen sie dazu also um was geht sie
mir denn sie haben schon richtig gesagt
ja genau
völlig richtig also eine subjekt und
hier sagt ja auch im die tiere sind
bloße objekte der zu und absprache von
vermögen und kräften durch den menschen
das ziel ist es wo sie objekt den wird
sagt jetzt montani willkürlich den
tieren wird willkürlich bestimmtes
zugesprochen bestimmtes abgespielt als
ihm gut denkt so nach lose willkür
beliebt also letztendlich geht es ihm um
ein ästhetisches problem sagt wir können
wir überhaupt wissen dass sie ist nicht
haben woher nehmen wir die die diesen
grund und mehr doch die arroganz oder
diese anmaßung ist eine anmaßung sagte
montana also dieses praktischen
moralisch verwerfliche systemische
einstellung gegenüber tieren ihr könnt
doch gar nicht wissen könnte doch anders
sein
über dieses problem des möglichen
wissens haben wir schon mal geredet ja
also das ist ein bisschen schwierig also
ich finde es einerseits durchaus
zutreffen dass er hier diesen
anthropozän tourismus brandmal stichwort
anthropozän tourismus wir menschen sehen
immer uns als maß der dinge an
das ist ein ästhetisches problem mit
ökologisches problem dass wir uns immer
dass wir immer beachten müssen wenn wir
über den geist der tiere sprechen
etwas anderes ist es dieses argument
hier woher man das denn wissen können
das haben wir ja gesehen das ist ein
bisschen problematisch wir müssen schon
irgendwelche anzeichen sehen die wir
dann natürlich ernst nehmen müssen
nachdem wir uns versucht haben aus
unserer haut heraus zu reflektieren was
nur schwer möglich ist
mythologisch jetzt aber das sagen woher
wissen wir es den der stein könnte doch
auch
gedanken haben das ist ein bisschen
problematisch weil wir müssen anzeichen
irgendwie haben wir müssen also sehr
sensibel sein für mögliche anzeichen
und die dürfen da nicht nur nach unserem
maßstab interpretieren wie wird zb bei
krems sehr gut sieht die krähe ist ein
gutes beispiel
da findet man ganz klar zeichen von
flexibilität und da wird auch teilweise
bei hochentwickelten affen wie coco
versucht kontakt aufzunehmen sagt kommt
so eine art austausch zustande
der affe kommt dann auf uns zu haben
sehen sich noch bei dieser dokumentation
da wurde gesagt ein intellektueller
exchange und ein window was geöffnet
wird
es waren sehr schöne metapher fand ich
die gerade dieses geistige bei tieren
bezeichnet haben es muss irgendwie eine
beziehung auch aufgenommen werden muss
ein tier in eine beziehung treten die
ihm angeboten wird und deswegen finde
ich dieses argument ein bisschen zu kurz
aber dennoch sehr montiert wie sie es
vielleicht noch ein punkt oder sonst
gehen wir zum nächsten wir sind alle
sehr sehr gute zitate brauchen wir einen
besseren beweis von der menschlichen
unverschämtheit in anziehen der tiere
diese große schriftsteller hat dafür
gehalten dass die natur meistenteils bei
der ihnen erteilten leibes bildung bloß
auf die gewöhnlichen vor bedeutungen
gesehen habe die man zu seiner zeit
darin suchte warum liegt der fehler
welcher den umgang zwischen uns und
ihnen hindert nicht eben sowohl an uns
als in ihm ist noch nicht ausgemacht an
wem der fehler liegt dass wir einander
nicht verstehen okay denn wir verstehen
sie ebenso wenig als sie uns verstehen
sie können uns aus eben dem grunde für
unvernünftig halten
aus welchen wir sie dafür halten es ist
kein großes wunder wenn wir sie nicht
verstehen
wir verstehen ja auch die biskaya und
die trockenen tüchern wissen dessen
haben sich doch einige sie zu verstehen
gerühmt als apollo news von tiana campus
theresia stars und andere und wenn wie
die erd- beschreibe berichteten gewisse
völker ein hund zu ihrem könige machen
so müssen sie doch wohl seine stimme und
seine bewegung zu verstehen glauben
was ist das argument auch bezogen auf
meine kritik jetzt an montani im
vorherigen zitat er hat jetzt in diesem
darauf folgend ein mögliches
gegenargument gebracht gegen mein
argument das war
wir können sie gar nicht wissen weil
kein zeichen gibt werden
das hat sagt er jetzt hier das ist
dieses herzen
also wurde hier noch genau dass wir
nicht gute einem guten punkt also und
das trifft ja auch scheint mir ein
problem weil wir eben immer dazu neigen
von uns selbst auszugehen als er wirft
den menschen vor die menschen versuchen
es ja gar nicht ehrlich sich meine das
tier hineinzuversetzen sie gehen ja
immer nur von sich aus und das finde ich
schon den legitimen vorwurf na also
diesen vorwurf gegen den antrag prozent
riss muss versucht euch mal liebe
menschen aus diesem antrieb prozent riss
muss heraus zu reflektieren
versucht euch mal hinein zu versetzen
das ist das thema hermeneutik zu
verstehen versteht doch mal die tür
öffnet euch doch mal für das wesen der
tiere es satt immer nur auf euch bezogen
das ist das hermeneutische prinzip das
verstehen ist das ist glaube ich guter
punkt wir brauchen ein tier hermeneutik
letztendlich richtig
genau richtig genau genau
wir kommen aus unsere haut nicht heraus
und selbst wenn wir einen neutralen
menschlichen beobachter konstruieren ist
es immer noch der mit neutrale
menschliche beobachtet dass menschen der
unbedingt
wichtig also das problem ist wie kommen
wir aus unserer haut heraus wie kommen
wir hinüber zum tier
also das ist auch dieses problem ich
möchte noch mal kurz wiederholen dass in
diesem seminar uns beschäftigt ist es
nicht nur das problem dass fremd
psychischen das könnte auch das fremd
psychische eines anderen menschen sein
ist das fremd psychische einer anderen
spezies
also ist liegt da noch eine natürliche
schwelle dazwischen nicht nur die kluft
zu einem anderen mentalen bewusstsein
sondern das mentale bewusstsein gehört
einer anderen art an als wir und das
macht die sache epidemisch noch einmal
viel komplexer letztes zitat wir müssen
nur auf die gleichheit die zwischen uns
und ihnen ist achtung geben wir
verstehen mittelmäßig was die tiere
haben wollen und fast ebenso gut
verstehen auch uns die tiere
sie schmeicheln sie drohen sie ersuchen
uns und dieses tun auch wir gegen sie
übrigens sehen wir sehr deutlich dass
unter ihnen ein verkommenes verständnis
ist und das nicht nur diejenigen die von
einer art sind sondern auch tiere von
verschiedene arten einander verstehen
hier finde ich jetzt dieses stichwort
verstehen sehr wichtig und das ist das
problem der hermeneutik verstehen wir
uns treten in irgendeinen austausch und
er sagt und das ist glaube ich ein guter
punkt tiere die verstehen sich schon
auch mit anderen worten die kommen
miteinander aus
die arrangieren sich liegt darin nicht
irgendwie ein anzeichen auch für eine
sprache oder eine höhere vernunft die
sich engagieren sich bei mir ja
einfinden letztes allerletzte zitat aus
einem gewissen bellen des hundes erkenne
das pferd deshalb zornig ist von einer
anderen stimme von ihm entsetzt er sich
nicht selbst bei denjenigen tieren die
keine stimme haben können wir aus den
gegenseitigen dienst bezeugungen leicht
schließen da sie durch irgendein anderes
mittel einverständnis miteinander
unterhalten müssen die ihre bewegungen
reden und das sind ja sehr schön sehr
schön ist hier also die sprache kann
sich auch auf große gesten konzentrieren
also kommunikation verständnis zeigt
sich nicht nur an der stimme am
materials an der form des bewegendes
interagieren
das finde ich sehr sehr guten gedanken
den er hier bringt darüber könnte man
sehr gut an es schreibe ich denke für
heute ist es genug wir sehen uns im
nächsten sitzungen lesen noch ein
bisschen mond ende und gehen dann weiter
mit anderen texten zu denen ich eben
auch noch schopenhauer mit hinzuziehen
möchte dann bis zur nächsten sitzung